Tief einatmen!
- Aua!
Ah!
Ich bin mitten
in der Bimbo-Transformation.
Ich möchte meinen Körper
eigentlich so weit optimieren,
dass irgendwann alles an mir
ziemlich künstlich ist.
* Popmusik *
Ich bin Aviva Rocks, bin 28,
arbeite als Webcam-Girl
und Pornodarstellerin
und bin vor Kurzem
nach Spanien ausgewandert.
* Popmusik *
Ich glaube, ich bin als Person
allgemein nicht wirklich
für die Gesellschaft gemacht -
also weder mit meinem Aussehen
noch mit meiner Denkweise,
meiner Einstellung,
meinem Job oder sonst etwas.
Foto conmigo!
Thank you! Thank you very much!
- Bye!
Ich geniesse das schon ein bisschen.
Ich mag es, wenn ich auffalle
und im Mittelpunkt stehe.
Gracias!
- Muy bien!
Adios!
* Popmusik *
Mir gefällt einfach
dieses Künstliche -
so dieses Fake, dieses Barbie.
Man nennt mich eben auch Bimbo.
Bimbo-Girl, Bimbo-Doll.
Ich habe halt blonde Haare,
schöne, pinkfarbene Lippen.
Ja, am besten würde man sehen,
dass an mir alles gemacht ist.
Darum ist es für mich
auch noch zu wenig,
was ich an mir habe machen lassen.
Die Nase ist noch zu natürlich.
Die Lippen sind im Moment
wieder zu natürlich.
Diese muss ich
auch wieder nachspritzen,
also dass sie
wie ein Schlauchboot aussehen.
Ja, es ist ...
Am besten alles
ein bisschen übertreiben,
dann gefällt es mir.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ah, jetzt ist einer reingekommen!
Ich verdiene mein Geld hauptsächlich
mit meinen Webcam-Shows.
Also mein Hauptjob ist Camgirl.
Nebenbei mache ich meine Pornoclips.
Tschüss!
Die sexuelle Lust
ist bei mir immer da.
Diese Veranlagung musst du haben.
Wenn eine sagt:
"Einmal Sex im Monat reicht mir!",
sage ich: "Ich glaube, Camgirl
ist nicht das Richtige für dich."
"Ich glaube,
du musst einen anderen Job haben."
Ja, du musst halt schon
Freude daran haben.
Also mein Ziel ist wirklich,
so gut wie nichts Natürliches mehr
an meinem Körper zu haben.
Bimbo ist einfach Plastik -
eben die Doll.
Barbie ist auch Plastik.
Das ist auch nicht echt.
Und sich dann halt auch so benehmen.
Also ein bisschen das Dummchen,
nicht ganz so intelligent.
Eine Puppe ist innen hohl.
Und Bimbo wird als Puppe,
als Doll, bezeichnet.
Und somit ist er halt auch hohl.
Am schönsten wäre natürlich
der Style einer Hummel:
eine richtig schlanke Taille,
hier XXL-Brüste und einen XXL-Arsch.
Und ich denke,
wenn ich mal alles operiert habe,
fängt alles wieder von vorne an:
Ich muss hier und dort
wieder etwas straffen.
Aber mir macht es ja zum Glück
Freude.
Einfach, dass ich weiss:
Jetzt kann ich mir wieder
eine OP leisten -
mit meinem verdienten Geld.
Ich kann hingehen,
wache auf und weiss,
dass ich wieder anders aussehe.
Und ich habe wieder etwas mehr
und bin meinem Ziel
von meinem eigenen Schönheitsideal
wieder etwas näher.
Das ist wahrscheinlich
das Adrenalin,
das man dann ausschüttet,
oder wie man das nennen will -
halt wie beim Tattoo:
Es ist zwar schmerzhaft,
aber man freut sich so sehr,
dass man es immer wieder will.
Ich würde schon sagen,
dass ich süchtig bin.
Kaum habe ich etwas operiert,
schaue ich,
was ich als Nächstes
operieren könnte.
Das ist schon eine Sucht, ja.
Das ist von meiner letzten Nasen-OP
mit der Stirnlift.
Da sieht man noch,
wo es angezeichnet wurde.
Dort haben sie aufgeschnitten.
Das war nach der letzten Brust-OP.
Die Heilung ist immer extrem mühsam.
Du darfst nichts machen.
Ich darf auch jetzt
keinen Sport treiben.
Du darfst zu Beginn
gar nichts machen:
kaum gehen, dich nicht bücken,
nichts hochheben.
Du kannst im Haushalt nichts machen.
Das nervt!
Das nervt von allem am meisten.
Aber trotzdem
hast du schnell wieder Lust,
wieder etwas zu machen.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ja, wann habe ich damit angefangen?
Ich war schon früh ein Fan davon.
Lolo Ferrari war natürlich ...
Das war in den 90er-Jahren.
Damals war ich relativ jung.
Ich himmelte sie
aber immer schon an -
also schon,
als ich acht Jahre alt war.
Ich habe im Fernsehen Dokus gesehen.
Dann kamen immer wieder solche.
Ich fand das einfach so interessant.
Ich sagte zu mir:
"Ich muss das einfach auch haben."
Und darum dachte ich:
"So, ich muss meinen Job wechseln!"
So kam ich zu Porno und Webcam.
Ich wollte damit
einfach Geld verdienen.
Und so ergab sich das alles.
Ich konnte eines nach dem anderen
operieren.
Ich spare jeweils wieder
ein halbes oder ganzes Jahr,
um das Nächste zu operieren.
Also das ist ungefähr ...
... sechs, sieben Jahre her.
Das ist ziemlich genau
sechs Jahre her.
Sechs Jahre.
Damals hatte ich schon meine Dogge,
aber als Baby.
Gott sei Dank
sehe ich nicht mehr so aus!
Ich finde das ganz schlimm!
Ich fühlte mich damals
auch nicht wohl und nicht hübsch.
Nichts!
Nein, ich bin ganz froh,
dass ich nicht mehr so aussehe.
Es wäre schlecht, wenn ich mich
jetzt ansehen und sagen würde:
"Scheisse, was habe ich da gemacht?"
Es gibt Essen.
Ja, ich habe noch
Muttertagsgeschenke - zum Verwöhnen.
Geschenke? Oh, danke schön!
- Du darfst es schon auspacken.
Ja, ich bin dran!
Hetz nicht so!
Wow!
- Ja.
Ui!
Mir persönlich gefällt es nicht.
Mir gefiel sie als mein Kind
natürlich besser.
Letztlich muss sie es wissen -
genauso, wie ich mein Leben lebe.
Sie redet mir auch nicht drein.
Sie kann mir zwar Tipps geben,
aber ob ich diese umsetze
oder nicht, ist mir überlassen.
Genauso kann auch ich zu ihr sagen,
ich fände es nicht so gut.
Aber mal davon abgesehen: Wenn ich
mich aufrege oder was weiss ich,
bringt es sowieso nichts.
Dann macht sie es erst recht.
Also lasse ich sie.
Sie soll sich wohlfühlen.
Irgendwann
merkt sie es vielleicht selbst.
Wenn nicht, wird es ihr so gefallen,
dass sie es durchzieht.
Dann ist es ja auch richtig.
* Rockmusik *
# Bang!
Ich bin endlich - nach genau vier
Monaten, habe ich ausgerechnet -
in die Schweiz gekommen,
um mich generalüberholen zu lassen,
denn ich habe es nötig.
Die Lippen sind viel zu klein.
Hier ist nichts mehr.
Die Haare sind vom Chlor
und Meerwasser ganz schlimm.
Und es gibt noch etwas Farbe
unter die Haut.
Das alles muss einfach sein.
# Bang, sayonara, bang!
Ich habe etwas Angst.
Es tut jedes Mal weh.
Die Tränen werden fliessen,
aber ich werde mich freuen,
dass ich endlich wieder so richtig,
richtig fette Lippen habe.
Ich mache sie so dick, dass ich
nicht mehr aus den Augen sehe.
# I've got an army in my head.
# My bullet brains.
Hallo!
Endlich bist du da!
- Ja.
Wie geht's?
- Gut! Gut siehst du aus!
Danke gleichfalls!
- Ja.
Machen wir heute die Lippen
und die Wangen?
Genau.
Du musst mal schauen.
Vielleicht hat es noch ein wenig.
Ja.
Ich will eigentlich wirklich Lippen
wie ein Cartoonfisch.
Das ist so
die perfekte Beschreibung.
Das Schlauchboot ...
- Also alles andere als natürlich?
Genau! Man soll aus 3 km sehen:
"Okay, sie hat Gummi in den Lippen."
Dann ist es richtig.
Da wirst du mich jetzt lieben.
Jetzt nochmals tief einatmen,
mein Schatz!
Ganz tief einatmen! Super!
- Aua!
Es ist auch ein Adrenalinschmerz,
der süchtig macht.
Es ist vergleichbar
mit dem Tätowieren.
Im Moment stirbst du
und denkst jedes Mal: "Warum?"
"Warum mache ich das?"
- Ja.
"Warum tue ich meinem Körper das an?
Warum?"
Und sobald es fertig ist, denkst du:
"Geil!
Zum Glück habe ich es gemacht!"
"Ich sehe wieder so schön aus!"
Und du denkst:
"Wann komme ich wieder?"
Ja!
"Wann geht's weiter?
Was könnte ich noch machen?"
"Was ist das Nächste?"
Aber die Lippen
sind am schmerzhaftesten.
Das stimmt, ja.
Aber du machst das super!
Auf dieser Seite
spritze ich noch ein bisschen.
Ja, super!
Deine neuen Lippen.
Ja, so habe ich das gewollt!
- Sehr schön!
Morgen
wird es noch extremer aussehen.
Ja, das ist definitiv so.
Aber ich liebe es,
den Einstich zu sehen.
Ich liebe das.
Wirklich?
- Ja, ich mag das sehr.
Du spinnst.
- Ja, absolut!
* Sanfte Musik *
Das ist
eine völlige Selbstoptimierung -
von meinem Körper,
von meinem Aussehen, für mein Leben,
für mein Glücklichsein,
damit ich zufrieden sein kann.
Ja, absolut!
* Sanfte Musik *
Jetzt gibt es neue Haare.
Es gibt neue Haare!
Wow, diese Auswahl!
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich glaube, der Bimbo-Lifestyle
ist etwas vom Teuersten ...
... was es gibt, nehme ich an.
Neben dem Bodybuilding,
was ich so von Freundinnen höre,
ist Bimbo-Lifestyle etwas
vom Kostspieligsten, das es gibt.
Man muss halt woanders
Abstriche machen und viel dafür tun.
Aber es muss jeder selber wissen,
was wichtig ist.
Mir macht das Freude,
einem anderen Fünf-Gänge-Menüs
für 100 Fr. oder 200 Fr. zu essen.
Ich lasse mir für dieses Geld
lieber die Haare machen.
Wenn man sich operieren lässt oder
etwas an seinem Körper vornimmt,
sollte man es nur
für sich selbst tun,
also nur sich selbst
glücklich machen
und es nicht für irgendeinen Mann,
Auftritt oder Fans machen.
Es ist schön,
wenn meine Fans Freude haben
und es mit mir zusammen
geniessen können,
aber nur, weil einer sagt,
ich solle das und das machen,
würde ich es nie tun.
* Sanfte Musik *
Eben!
Das ist immer das Schlimmste.
Also, es geht los.
Du sagst einfach ...
Ja.
* Sanfte Musik *
Oh!
Ich gestalte so
einfach meinen Körper, mein ...
... ja, mein Ich.
Ich gestalte es so,
wie es mir gefällt -
ob das jetzt mit OPs ist
oder mit kosmetischen Eingriffen,
Tätowierungen, Haare färben,
Make-up, Kleidern ...
Ich mache es so, wie es mir gefällt.
Ich musste schon meine ID erneuern.
Sie hatten an der Grenze
mein Gesicht nicht mehr erkannt,
mit den Gesichtszügen ...
- Oh!
Ja, voll krass!
* Sanfte Musik *
Privat höre ich halt so Death Metal,
Thrash Metal, New Metal ...
Ich höre viele Metal-Stile.
Und mir gefällt alles,
was mit Grusel zu tun hat,
mit Totenköpfen,
Horrorsachen und Splattersachen,
blutiges Zeug.
Das gehört halt auch ein bisschen
zu meiner Persönlichkeit.
Ich hatte - Gott sei Dank -
eine sehr schöne Kindheit.
Ich durfte bei meinen Grosseltern
aufwachsen.
An den Wochenenden
durfte ich bei meinen Eltern sein.
Sie arbeiteten beide zu 100 %.
Viele glauben auch,
dass Leute, die sich so umgestalten,
eine schlimme Kindheit,
irgendein Trauma
oder so etwas hatten.
Ich kann mit Glück sagen,
dass ich so etwas nicht hatte.
* Sanfte Musik *
Ich bin total happy! Total!
Total!
Jetzt sehe ich mein wahres Ich,
denn allmählich sehe ich so aus,
wie ich mich fühle.
Vorher hatte ich immer schlimme
Komplexe und fühlte mich nicht wohl.
Ich war nicht zufrieden mit mir.
Jetzt habe ich einfach Freude.
Ich kann darüber reden, es zeigen,
meine Erfahrungen
mit den Operationen,
mit den Eingriffen mitteilen.
Jetzt bin ich ich, was ich vorher,
ohne die Eingriffe, nicht war.
* Sanfte Musik *
Bimbo oder auch das Aussehen ist
auch das, was mich glücklich macht,
dass ich so aussehen kann,
wie ich will,
dass ich noch mit 50 so aussehen
kann, wie ich mir das vorstelle,
wie ich mir das wünsche
und wie es mir gefällt,
und nicht denke:
"Oh nein! Wie sehe ich aus?"
Das ist natürlich schon das Ziel:
dass ich das auch mit 50 habe, ja.